what's more likely time with week 13 of
the 2020 season upon us let's begin with
one of the more significant games of the
weekend if the browns actually show up
you know they've got a history of not
showing up when it's time to play a good
team the browns at the titans both teams
eight and three cleveland has what's
more likely cleveland has
175 yards or more rushing or derrick
henry has on his own 125 yards or more
rushing what's more likely yeah it's a
good one i mean those two running backs
in cleveland you know we know how
special they are and they're going to
run the ball i mean just like tennessee
their game and offense goes through the
run game i'm going to go but derek henry
has 125 plus rush yards though that'll
be my go-to uh i think the the big
reason for me more than anything is
tennessee titans have big people and
their run defense has been better as of
late they're numbers of where they're
ranked in the nfl and how many rushing
yards they let up per game and all that
are a little skewed because early in the
year they had issues the jaguars the
vikings just piled up huge numbers
against them but as of late it's been
much better so i think between that and
then cleveland not being a real great
run stopping defense themselves i'm
going to go with derek henry on this one
yeah i think so too and for me it's far
simpler than that he has slid into a
groove and we've seen this in the past
he gets into that late season zone and
he becomes unstoppable and even even
with
as we were trying to figure out what
happened what was different
the left tackle gone
for the season with the torn acl
suffered earlier in the year that that
seemed to be the point where the running
game started to dip
well it's gone the other way they've
adjusted yeah they're fine and derek
henry has had 55 carries combined over
the last two weeks i think he's going to
get his chances he's going to get his
yards and uh we're going to be doing our
mega pix podcast later today i'd be
stunned if either of us pick the browns
to win because the browns have to beat a
good team before we're going to believe
that they can beat a good team that's
right that's right and we saw i think
what scares me more than anything to
mike is a few weeks ago we saw them play
a team like this
in the in the las vegas
raiders right and it was a bad uh
weather day and all that and the raiders
ran the ball on them you know
cleveland's stats and numbers are
stopping the run you know they're a
little fortunate they've played a lot of
teams who can't really run the ball this
year so that that's added to them
looking a little bit better but that'll
be interesting to see but yeah my
money's on derek henry and vrabel in
that company there
eagles and the packers get together
remember last year the philadelphia
eagles went into green bay on a thursday
night bless you and won the game what's
more likely this time around jalen hurts
the backup quarterback who got a couple
of snaps the other night what's more
likely he has three passes in the first
half of the game or aaron rodgers has
three touchdown passes in the first half
of the game
i would go out of those two i mean i
think it's very realistic that neither
one of those happened okay but i'm going
it's not the choice i know i'm gonna go
in there and if you're gonna make me
pick one of them then i'm gonna go with
aaron rodgers three tds in the first
half i am yeah hey uh the one eagles
will play man to play a lot of
man-to-man they're gonna give them some
opportunities you know whether they can
get open and make the throw and catching
all that that's one thing but there's
going to be some you know appetizing
looks to where roger's going to look and
go whoa they're going to play us like
that they're going to play us like that
and i mean jalen hurts
we've seen three passes the whole year i
just i can't go with that yet
yeah and and i think there is a tension
there regarding taking carson wentz out
putting jalen hurts in and maybe on a
short week maybe with less time to
really think about it i don't know maybe
they go back to a place where they were
successful last year maybe that's a
moment where something happens for
carson wentz where he can exercise some
demons because he remembers going to
lambeau field and winning on a thursday
night it was a close exciting game and
it's just it just still amazes me i've
been racking my brain trying to think of
somebody who's had this career arc where
second overall pick plays well mvp
candidate gets the big contract and then
there it goes yeah by all appearances
but it's gone and he's trying hard to
get it back all right rams at cardinals
sneaky great game first time this season
two division rivals meeting week 13
they'll meet twice between now and the
end of the regular season critical games
rams seven and four cardinals six and
five what's more likely rams cornerback
jaylen ramsey gets an interception or
cardinals receiver deandre hopkins
catches a touchdown yeah this is a great
likely yeah great matchup right i mean
these two i mean gosh they're in the
same division jaylen ramsey he went out
to the rams and signed a big contract
and now he's got to deal with dk metcalf
and de andre hopkins for the rest of his
career i mean
interceptions are rare
like jalen ramsey could win the better
better of this matchup and and win more
plays and have a really awesome day and
deandre hopkins could still catch a td
and zone or some pick play or they're at
the three yard line on some wide
receiver screen so i'm gonna go with
deandre hopkins catches the td just
because interceptions are very rare and
hey i got a lot of the times with guys
like the you know jaylen ramsey he's so
good quarterbacks don't want to mess
with them or when they do look over
there and think oh maybe i'll try my guy
he's not open to throw the ball there
anyways now ramsay's health a little bit
i know he had a little hip issue before
last week that'll be something to watch
for but i'm going with hopkins in that
catching the td
i didn't notice his name on the injury
report last night i may have to check
that again but i was i i was i was
struck by the revelation from coach sean
mcvay that he was limited to 50 reps of
the 72 on defense because he had a hip
thing that popped up before the game
there was no hip injury last week i
don't think there's one on the report
this week but that's something to watch
and look i agree with you dion sanders
never had many interceptions because he
didn't throw his way right they don't
throw your way you're covering your guy
they're not going to do something stupid
and give you an interception you're
keeping your guy though from from
catching passes and catching touchdowns
but i agree with you between these two
choices it's more likely to happen
they've got a history
to do you know that's what's cool
they've been playing each other i've
i've talked to jaylen ramsey you know
and asked him about receivers that give
him issues deandre hopkins was the first
guy he brought up when we had a
conversation you know because deandre
hopkins physical tough
crafty route runner all those type of
things but yeah that's a that's a cool
one they they have a respectable
very intense physical rivalry together
that's fun to watch and anybody you know
watching football sunday that's one i
would tell anybody to watch and tune
into and keep your eye on
tune in next week for
pft live because at the top of the hour
on monday tuesday or wednesday there
will be a sims-ism segment devoted to
the new word that's been added to the
lexicon another page we're going to need
a bigger boat it's great too when you
don't even realize that's what makes it
even better
respectful oh respect respectful
respectful yes simsism number
372. yeah all right
next game
but i agree more likely that deandre
hopkins scores a touchdown pass saints
nine and two at falcons four and seven
they're getting together for the second
time in three weeks what's more likely
the saints rush for 175 or more yards or
quarterback taysom hill throws his first
career touchdown pass and so far in the
two starts with taysom hill 166 and 229
rushing yards for the saints offense it
wasn't pretty
last week you know obviously the
quarterback situation in denver new
orleans went into the game plan and into
the game with a very you know let's be
conservative type game plan but taysom
hill just from watching that film back
it wasn't the prettiest i've seen him
play you know the first week i was
encouraged by what we saw the second
week i kind of went eh you know i think
there were some things there that'll
concern sean payton didn't see the field
all that well missed some open receivers
you know his pocket presence wasn't all
that great um you know so that that'll
be something to watch for here mike i
don't know where do you where do you lie
on this i'm gonna go
i'm gonna go with taysom hill throws his
first career td pass
i'm gonna go there this was a week i i
just think raheem morris and atlanta the
way they're playing right now
i think they're gonna smother that run
game i just have a hard time thinking
that that's how new orleans is going to
win this football game they're going to
make it to where tesa mill has to throw
to beat them and i'll say this is the
week he finally gets his first career td
pass
and you know that's a good point too it
could be that raheem morris decides
we're not going to be suffocated in the
run game we're going to sell out to stop
it i think and let's see if this tight
end turned quarterback can beat us over
the top i just yeah when you think about
red zone though what do we see so often
now with taysom hill we don't see a
throw to the back of the end zone we see
the bull in a china shop
run
to the goal line right and it works so
you're you're not plays that otherwise
would have become potential touchdown
passes for taysom hill are touchdown
runs for taysom hill he's had two in
each of the last two games and uh uh i i
think that uh i but i
i don't know that the falcons are
capable of it now they're going to be
feeling good about themselves after
blowing out the raiders i don't know
what that translates into this weekend
there is a great rivalry there and they
aren't going to want to be embarrassed
i'll go with you first touchdown pass of
the career more likely than 175 or more
rush yards all right colts and texans
together for the first time this year
they play twice in three weeks i believe
seven of four colts four and seven
texans desean watson throws an
interception or he has his seventh
straight game without one he's had 15
touchdown passes and zero picks over the
last six weeks chris what's more likely
a pick or he continues his streak of no
pick game i'm gonna go with no pick
games i mean he's on fire right now so
i'm gonna ride ride the wave with him
you know it's the perfect example again
to just show everybody out there too
like the game is bigger than just one
guy desean watson
i don't know how anybody can watch the
sport and not think he's one of the five
or six best quarterbacks in the game i
mean he's he's phenomenal talent i mean
i just don't know what else to say about
him i mean he really is amazing and yes
it's this great year he's having is
getting lost in the shuffle because
they're an average football team and i
give you a lot of credit for writing
that little article last week kind of
giving him credit that he deserves
because it's it's amazing what he does
even when there's crap around him and
everything there
i'll i think he's in the groove he
realizes he's got to play almost perfect
football for them to even be in close
games or win a game i'm going to say he
stays hot here uh against the colts and
and doesn't throw an interception
but it is the colts i mean it is the
colts so i uh all good things come to an
end i say he's going to get a
description this weekend against the
colts defense because look the colts
they're feeling a higher sense of
urgency after getting bullied by the
titans they they fall to seven and five
they gotta start worrying about tumbling
out of the playoff picture all together
there's going to be one or two good
teams teams that we had at some point
this year looked at and said oh yeah
they'll definitely make the playoffs
right they don't make the playoffs yeah
when the dust settles on the afc they
need to force buckner back this week
which i think he is back right that'll
be big they missed him last week one of
those times mike where you you don't
realize how good a guy is or how awesome
he is for a defense until you watch them
without it and then you start to go i
don't think the titans could have done
that if buckner was there i don't think
that play would have worked if buckner
was there uh he is one of the best in
the game and they need him back
the f up the play mentality and buckner
was on covet 19 last week it's always
unclear when a guy can come back i think
he was a positive test too so you're
right that complicates things as well
broncos and chiefs on sunday night
football denver's four and seven they
will have their quarterbacks this week
as far as we know the chiefs have
patrick mahomes which always puts them
in a position to win and they are still
trying to chase down the steelers for
the one seed so they have every
incentive to have a big game what's more
likely tyree kill has more than 150
yards
receiving or he has fewer than 100 on
the night what's more like i'm gonna go
with under a hundred this week uh you
know fangio he's too smart on the
defensive side of the ball i don't think
he's gonna give them a whole lot of
opportunities to be making big plays
he'll know when to you know help out on
tyree kill in certain situations like
that and the denver secondary you know
it's pretty damn good you know when you
talk about aj bouier right now he's
playing good you know of course justin
simmons one of the best safeties in
football william jackson right there
along with them you know they're well
coached in the background in the back
end in denver and they got talent back
there too you know because of that i i
don't think they'll let hill go off i'm
going to go with the under
tyree kill uh had only 55 yards when
they got together earlier this year it
was a blowout win by the broncos but uh
defense had a lot to or by the chiefs
excuse me defense had a lot to do with
that i remember last year
when the broncos and the chiefs got
together in december it was a snowy day
and and that was
kind of the first time we started to
wake up to the idea that even though
we're obsessed with the ravens and the
49ers in 2019 there was an opportunity
there for the kansas city chiefs to kind
of sneak up on everyone yeah and win the
whole thing which they ultimately did
tyree kills had a hundred yards
receiving for three straight games but
last week was his first game this season
with more than 150 i'm with you i think
it's going to be under 100. broncos
defense is good it's good and and
even though it's a prime time game it's
not the kind of opponent that's going to
have the chiefs locked in
that's just a focus issue with the
chiefs and and they are a team that is
vulnerable because the broncos are going
to be coming at them with everything
they have this is their super bowl what
else are the broncos playing for they're
four and seven they're not going to the
playoffs so if they could if they could
hang a loss on the chiefs in prime time
you know this is kind of like the reason
last week we thought the texans would
beat the lions it was the texan super
bowl this is it this is the only time
anybody's going to care about the texans
sure the rest of the year sunday night
is the only time anyone's going to care
about the broncos the rest of the year
so i think that that adds up to yeah
maybe a closer game and also fewer than
100 yards per time i think it's a good
point though you're right i mean hey
drew lock he's fighting to make sure
he's the starting quarterback there next
year it's an important team
game for a lot of people in that
organization yeah i don't expect them to
win but at fangio and denver that
defense they were pretty damn successful
the first time around i know they lost
the game but you know
they do a good job of managing the
chiefs offense they really have so uh
we'll see where that goes but you know
the chiefs are dangerous and of course i
expect them to win the football game
and there is a lot going on around that
broncos organization we've had stories
over the past few days there's
litigation among the bolin family there
was a statement issued yesterday by beth
bolland wallace saying it's time to
transition ownership to someone this
team has been held in a trust for the
past seven or eight years as the
trustees wait for one of the seven
children of pat boland to show that he
or she is ready to run the team and the
way this is all going long story
bearable this may all be rocketing
toward a selling of the team at some
point uh and uh because they just can't
get along and at some point they're all
gonna have to sign off on one of the
siblings running the team whoever the
trustees pick but if the rest of them
say no we're not doing it
you you only have one alternative which
is to put the team on the market so
there's just a lot of dysfunction and
turmoil and this team which had a proud
tradition of not racking up consecutive
losing seasons i think they're they're
closing in on four in a row this year so
uh this is their moment this is their
chance and maybe they'll play a little
bit better on sunday night
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports